we showed you a pretty hilarious footage
from a new Tony fauci documentary last
night it showed that fauci knew less
about science and some random people in
the poorest neighborhood in DC it was
truly funny so today we watched more of
it and we were not disappointed you
really should see this
the film crew caught Tony fauci crying
during Joe Biden's inauguration
today is uh a combination of so many
different things
it's kind of a
a
diffusion of an incredible amount of
pent-up tension
holding back of of despair
[Music]
[Applause]
clapping alone in his sad little
apartment the more you know about the
people in charge the less reassuring it
is but there were other candid scenes
from this document we cannot recommend
this enough here's Tony fauci taking his
second out of like 40 covet shot
I got my second vaccine yesterday and I
feel like today
oh he had a vaccine reaction he must be
a conspiracy theorist
IC clay Travis is without kick.com he
joins us tonight I can't we got to kick
that man off Twitter he's claiming he
had an adverse reaction to a vaccine
I want this man I know everybody's
focused on the Donald Trump perk walk uh
uh uh Tucker I want fauci in handcuffs
more than I've ever wanted anyone in
handcuffs in my life I never would have
believed Tucker that after O.J Simpson
got away with double murder some 80 year
old NIH bureaucrat would have risen to
the level that Dr fauci has but Tucker I
you mentioned the guy in DC on the porch
who questioned fauci directly for two
minutes that guy on the porch questioned
fauci more aggressively on covid than
left-wing media did for three years one
guy on the porch and what I love about
this documentary too is fauci thought
that he was going to be the hero here
instead all it's providing now is a
tangible record of all all his lies
everything that he has been wrong about
immortalized forever including some
things like masking that he claims he
never even said in the first place I
love it I'm gonna watch I want him in
handcuffs
I think he's already in a sad lonely
hell
um but after so he treats that guy like
a zoo animal the guy is a really good
point like really you can make a vaccine
that fast no he can dispatch and then he
goes back in the car and puts on hand
sanitizer because he was in that man's
proximity he's just dirty
and how about DC's mayor is there with
fauci and she says I wouldn't even be
standing this close to you if I hadn't
gotten my shot and then I think she
tested positive for covid shortly
thereafter of course because I guess
it's going to be the seventh or eighth
shot that solves it all but fauci is a
fraud Rand Paul's right this guy belongs
in handcuffs can we get a perp walk on
this dude sooner rather than later
sure I want to see any more
documentaries like this I don't really
want to know what these people are like
it's always confirming of every
suspicion clay Travis great to see you
tonight thank you very much for that
thanks doctor appreciate it subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight